this one issue of time management has
been with me throughout my entire life
and it's
probably the best it's ever been what do
you say to people
when they're just eviscerating
themselves in those moments
well you know anyone can try to build a
perfect schedule but i think real time
management is about building a resilient
schedule and that is a schedule that can
deal with the fact that a meeting ran
long or the kids are sort of
dilly-dallying on their way to school
and so you just have to build in
extra space and the only way you can
build an extra space
is by taking on fewer things i'm saying
this is how long this is going to take
i'll add in a little extra you know i
thought i could do 20 things in a day
maybe i should
take that down to about 10 knowing that
some things are going to run longer
things are going to come up that's life
we got to expect that right
what are we going to do what would you
be willing to give up
i don't i don't know i would have to
think about that
helen's like nothing how's that for an
answer i'm willing to give up nothing
um i don't know what i could give up
either
well you could try scheduling things a
little bit longer than you think they
will take so if you think a meeting will
run
30 minutes block in 45 block in an hour
you know just trying to leave a little
earlier how you can
leave a day open in the sort of macro
sense of how do we fit things into our
lives i try not to schedule things on
friday as much as possible because that
way
when things run over from earlier in the
week there's somewhere for them to go
okay so can i
do the test of your book really quick to
the room
how long does everybody think like i
want to say hours minutes like are is in
a lifetime
in the span of a lifetime like take a
few guesses
we could give them a hint so there's 8
760 hours in a year
so we can all do math now i went to law
school i came to man
800 000 would get you to about 90 90
years some
so that would be i would have thought
there were
millions and millions and trillions of
hours in a life
i don't want to go on like this anymore
how many hours do i have left where i'm
gonna sit there and like
you're bad you're wrong i have to fix
this
yeah no we we need to feel good about
life because it's the only one we have i
mean one thing
i try saying and trying to have other
people say to themselves is that really
expectations are infinite you know but
time
is finite and so because of that
we're always choosing what we do
and so all we can do is making sure that
we are choosing well
in any given moment choosing what we
would like to be spending some of these
precious hours on the planet doing and
if you can always say that you
are making that choice that you are
happy about that choice
i think time starts looking a lot
different whoa
that's part of why i just
highly highly highly respect you the
type a and me
saw your breakdown and like was like oh
my god having
like breathe into a paper bag but
hearing that i feel so
liberated and i feel so
incentivized and motivated to meet you
there
do you have any advice for helen and
i other than the profound statement that
you just made
well one practical thing is is to think
about your life in weeks i think many
times when people feel like they are
running out of time
it's because they're looking at each
individual day and you get to the end of
the day and you say i didn't do
everything that is important to me well
of course not
you know it's one day but we don't have
to do everything that is important to us
every single day so look at the whole of
the week and you'll feel far better
about any given day
you know so if you can look at your time
and say well here are three wonderful
things i did today or here are three
moments when i felt
totally in control then that can become
your story instead i mean we're in
charge of what we tell ourselves
we're our biggest critics right i feel
like i'm always my biggest critic
like who really is watching my time
management like
but me what do you what's your theory
really quickly before
we're done about like getting there five
minutes early and having that window of
like
wasting time or luxuriating in that
yeah well estimating how long stuff will
take is very difficult
and so that's why people are always late
right that they can't figure out how
long it will take to get from place to
place or
you know think it'll be the perfect trip
because it once took 15 minutes when
there was no traffic but now there's
traffic
um so yeah get aim to get there five
minutes early and because people are
often
mistaken about how long things take
aiming to get there five minutes early
means you'll probably be
about on time and baruch said that
we as a society do not feel comfortable
with wasting time
so we will wait till the last minute or
we won't think of it as a goal
of like five minutes to waste but he
says all human beings
waste in every sense of the word so
why when it comes to time do we think
it's such a sin
to waste and having that five minutes to
luxuriate
and maybe take a moment to say like
you're doing well
do you think that that is time wasted or
is that time
gained whenever you are happy with how
you are spending your time
then it isn't wasted at all i feel time
is so much better when we approach it
from a perspective of
abundance and sometimes having that
abundant perspective
means being willing to waste a few
minutes here and i put waste in quote
marks because again
if you feel good about your time then it
isn't wasted at all
then this seems like a solvable problem
does this
sound like something you can apply in
your life what laura is saying
i think i love the what you said about
if we're happy doing what we're doing
at that moment that's all that's
important
and i think that i'm going to write that
down on all one of my stickies that's
covering my office
um laura i can't thank you enough i've
been such an uber fan and such an
admirer and i read your book
several years ago and it was one of the
most eye-opening books i'd ever read oh
thank you
and helen i'm so grateful that i got to
go into this very personal and raw
endeavor
with a really good person and someone
who we both can realize that life
is good we are happy and this is
something we can really tackle
and like can we keep in touch about it
for sure okay good
okay thank you and laura would you
please come back
anytime all right thank you so much by
the way there's a man named dan glance
who's probably
losing his mind right now over our time
you